as we told you yesterday about 1 million
species of animals and plants around the
world are now at risk of extinction in
part due to pollution and overfishing a
new United Nations report says nature is
essential for our existence and a good
quality of life but points to a start
warning
humans are transforming the planet's
natural habitat at an unprecedented rate
Jonathan Vigliotti is in Los Angeles
eluate in Los Angeles with what the
future could look like if nothing's done
Jonathan good morning and good morning
John scientists say the report is a
landmark in the conservation battle not
only was it compiled by scientists
hundreds of them it was approved by
diplomats as well from 132 countries
including here in the US they say human
survival depends on healthy animals and
plants and destroying them ultimately
hurts us from penguins and killer whales
in Antarctica to orangutan in Indonesia
and sea turtles on the Great Barrier
Reef animals all over the world find
their habitat threatened by human
activities like unsustainable farming
and pollution and their very survival is
at stake biodiverse is important for
human wellbeing and we humans are
destroying it although it was notable
for being comprehensive the reports
specifics came as no surprise to some
we're looking at a crisis I mean we're
really this is Code Red
dr. Thomas Smith is with the UCLA
Institute of environment and
sustainability biodiversity is is
basically all the living parts of the
planet and that includes us so we depend
on animals and plants for our food for
our pollinators if we lose those
elements
we're losing the essentially the
resources that humans use to survive
unless society makes what it calls
transformative changes the report
predicts that in the next few decades
more than 40% of amphibian species could
go extinct along with over one third of
marine mammals and more than one-third
of the world's coral reefs that give
them life people depend on the fish
stocks that come out of that for
subsistence
CBS News has circled the planet to show
how loss of animals and plants can
impact human populations from the waters
off Australia to the Brazilian Amazon
which creates weather systems that cool
the world without these forth the world
a much hotter and drier place
scientists note that more than seven
billion people on this planet depend on
the delicate balance of biodiversity to
survive and while the human population
is growing the earth's resources are not
if action is taken now can this be
reversed on a large scale I think if
people become involved I'm hopeful every
day I come into work I have to be
hopeful because you know there's no
alternative and hope and we can make a
difference if we put our mind to it and
Smith says massive change can require
simple steps but they must be taken
collectively including things like using
eco-friendly products driving our cars
less and even eating less meat and I did
some research into hamburger something
I've indulged in from farm-to-table the
average hamburger uses more than 600
gallons of water and Nora six pounds of
greenhouse gases so you could see how
quickly things add up all right Jonathan
thank you